Up to now you've built your
first mapping applications
where you saw how to set up
the Google Maps API and integrate and
authenticated map into your application.
You saw the map fragment and
user interface.
And you saw how to use that
to get a Google Map object
that you could then manipulate and code.
In the last lesson we modified
a lot of properties of the map.
And it's often helpful to think of
them as being properties of a camera
floating over the landscape.
You could look at it as the cameras on
an aircraft that's flying over the map.
So as well as setting latitude and
longitude of the location
you want to look at.
There's also cool stuff like setting the
direction of the cameras looking in and
the angle at which it looks at the map.
The camera doesn't always
have to point straight down
as well as having the ability to
animate the movement of the camera
giving the impression of
flying over a landscape.
In this last end,
we'll do a lot of work with the camera.
And we'll see how it can be used
to build better maps for your apps